and the real question is okay we're
looking for the maximum possible volume
alright so patsy remember your training
now this is turn into a max min question
properly so what am I gonna do this
thing what do you do with normal maximum
questions you find the derivative let's
differentiate this thing it looks like a
question do I do question rule for the
first reason that we always try and
avoid it but secondly like this thing
down here is it's a constant if you saw
this and I asked you to differentiate it
you wouldn't say ah vu - - you know you
wouldn't do that you'd say this is 1/5
times whatever okay so in fact there is
something I can do to work on this a
little more this is really a polynomial
of some kind right do you see there's an
R squared there that means it's at least
a quadratic but it's actually more than
that what's it going to end up happening
when I expand out this is gonna be a
cubic right so what I want to do like
this like I want to separate out what's
the constant coefficient take that out
of the way write it like that okay now
it's easy I want to separate all the
constants out so I actually can't
simplify this a little more tell me what
kinds of constants I can remove there
are some easy ones you can identify
maybe the first thing yeah it's a
constant so I'm just gonna write that
first okay
that's variable so I'll come back to
that in a second is that a constant yes
so I'm gonna put that there
well that this is that a constant yes so
this all comes out the front like a
fifth right few notes it might be a
fifth after you put all the bits and
pieces together okay and now come the
variables so I'm gonna write this as
there's an R squared and there's an R -
R so that's a bit tangled up in there
okay but that's okay I can I can
simplify this as well I can say hmm this
is PI H point R outside of uh squared
whoops ah - ah cute did I explain
correct look okay all right now I'm
really differentiate this is about I
mean I could expand again but
everything's gonna have a PI H on our on
it so there's no advantage okay
so now I'm going to say DV on what here
thank you very much
capo our differentiate with to that guy
people do by the way because it looks
like you can and then of course you get
something that's that doesn't make any
sense
so because I'm the constants already out
the front
oops I'm gonna write it what's happening
tomorrow that's a bit weird
that's better okay so now I'm going to
differentiate these guys decide just one
at a time okay what's the derivative for
this two little R capital R yeah because
remember that that guy is just the
constant what about this what's that
become three capital R squared
derivative done now that I have a
derivative what do I do with it for
maximum question let's look for some
stationary points because hopefully some
of them are not just stationary points
they are turning points okay I don't
know that for sure by the way C hat is a
cubic sometimes they have our horizontal
points of inflection when we're about to
find out okay so I would say turning
points because that's what I'm searching
for they may exist because remember
they're guarantees I might turn up with
a horizontal point inflection there may
exist when the derivative is zero
capital R can I give you a moment to
take over from here and see how far you
can get don't forget if you find
something you got to test it you don't
know what kind of station important it
is so have a go with that
and call me over if you think you've got
an idea so just in case you may be not
with us what have I done I'm sorting for
when the derivative is equal to zero so
that I can find a stationary point I
find one please note I get to this point
here okay what have I done from this
line to this line I've gotten rid of
that PI H on our little H a little R
because all that's a constant doesn't
contribute anything to my solutions and
then get to this point and I notice what
I factorize so one of these has to be
zero but but this is that radius that
we're looking at it can't be zero I'm
not gonna have a cylinder so therefore I
note that it's irrelevant I can't get a
solution from there this is the other
part come down to this number which is
amazingly simple this is one of the
reasons
why mathematicians love Nachman in
geometry for instance if I gave you a
circle and I said here's a rectangle
that's inscribed what is the largest
area of the rectangle you can find and
it happens to be a square it's exactly a
square or if you do a triangle it's
exactly an equilateral triangle so you
get some of these weirdly perfect like
exactly 2/3 it's where that magic spot
is okay so this is where I'm expecting
to find something you notice that I go
to the second derivative I don't choose
the first why how did I choose that okay
so the first like the actual the reason
why I have to make a choice is because I
need to determine nature I didn't say
that I probably should have but um why
in terms of knowing I had to determine
the nature why did I choose secondary
roof rather than the first color code
number what what is the deciding factor
in whether you choose the first or
second review it's on the board what's
the deciding factor this is the first
derivative is it easy to differentiate
now I know it looks like a mess doesn't
it it looks terrible but constant
constant constant constant this is just
a polynomial dressed up in terrible
clothes that's the easiest kind of thing
to differentiate no quotients or
anything like that involved that's the
main thing you have to watch out for so
I go ahead there's there's my second
derivative you can see I don't have to
worry about that it's a constant this is
what happens on the inside and then I
get to here I test my particular point
now what does this mean what I expecting
what am I expecting I'm expecting
concave down because I'm searching for a
maximum now does that tell me that this
is concave down the answer is yes but
only because of something that we
noticed which I've unfortunately rubbed
off which is that this thing here right
if it were negative then the whole thing
would not be concave down would it
why can I say that this is a negative
it's a length it's it's the height of
the current right so that's actually
really important that the sign of the
second really depends on the sign of
that pronumeral right there but I know
that I know the sign of it so I have to
actually just say that right but H is
greater than zero
it's a length okay on that basis not
because I wanted to because it's
convenient on that page just I can say
therefore the second derivative is less
than 0 okay
which means it's concave down therefore
I can say at that I have a maximum now
you notice I said a maximum because
remember your training
this is a max min question stationary
points even turning points even maximum
turning points may not be the actual
maximum in a given situation where else
might add-- occur
you're any other attorney if you have to
the turning point are the end points
okay now we're talking about capital R
here everything's in terms of capital R
what is the biggest that capital R could
possibly be look at your diagram the
biggest that capital R possibly P would
be little R right that's you make it the
widest possible thing that fits in the
cone but of course if those two things
are the same then what happens to the
height of our cylinder it's zero so you
have no volume so it's clearly not a
maximum that's the biggest that the
radius can get what is the smallest the
radius can get zero and then you have
the same problem okay so in this case I
can actually ignore my endpoints if you
wanted to say it and I don't think you
need to but it's probably nice in this
archetypal example that we say it I
would say four endpoints yeah four
endpoints R equals R and R equals zero
give no volume so I don't think you
really need to worry about saying that
like you would not lose a mark if you
didn't say that but I like to say it
because I want to make sure I'm always
looking out for end points just like I'm
always looking out for a domain
restriction because I often forget those
so at long last I have an answer right
is that my answer is that my answer no
because remember your training you have
to actually answer the question what is
the question I'm looking for the actual
volume right not the dimensions that
give me such a volume so this is the
easy part
there for maximum volume is okay
I have an expression for volume over
there let's have a go at it it's PI H on
oh well I'm not gonna write that because
I know what this big R is don't know
there it is right there so let's
substitute this in now okay 2/3 squared
minus 2/3 cubed
yeah look good
conveniently you can see here with some
of your numbers that this is going to
lead to some nice simplification in here
because this R squared is with an R
right so what am I going to get here for
R cubed on look carefully nine right
take away what are we gonna get here how
many are cubes are you gonna have on the
top aide cute on 27 bit of
simplification that's going to happen
here
and also that 9 is not very useful we
should change that into 27 I suppose so
that leaves me with PI H 12 127 take
away 8 we're almost there how many are
squares left 4 4 PI R squared H 2 that
catch them all on the numerator I think
they're all there on 27 exhale oh yeah
we got there okay so this there is a lot
of work to this part of why is because
maximum questions on their own are large
objects and then we add all of this
there's other stuff in terms of geometry
like oh my goodness this is similar
triangles thing in here okay so HSC
examiners like these questions they're
quite fond which is why in the HSC
questions are essentially there's quite
a few instances of this and there's a
lot of thinking involved so I apologize
the day that took so much time but I
hope it sort of gives you a bit of
confidence now to tackle these when you
have a look at them in the future okay